era uno de los militares clave en el
gobierno de bachar al-assad responsable
de los servicios de inteligencia del
presidente sirio y ahora el ex
funcionario de más alto rango condenado
en un juicio histórico por crímenes de
lesa humanidad por las atrocidades
cometidas durante la guerra civil de ese
país anwar ras lanuf fue acusado de 58
asesinatos violaciones y agresiones
sexuales en el centro de detención al
katiba llamado también rama 251 en
damasco supervisado por una unidad de
inteligencia que él dirigía y en el que
al menos cuatro mil opositores fueron
torturados entre 2011 y 2012 las pruebas
en su contra documentos que él mismo
presentó a las autoridades migratorias
alemanas cuando llegó a pedir asilo en
2012 en esta nación los tribunales
pueden condenar crímenes de lesa
humanidad cometidos en cualquier parte
del mundo entonces esto es realmente
histórico porque mientras rusia a veces
con la ayuda de china ha bloqueado los
esfuerzos para enviar las atrocidades
sirias a la corte penal internacional
todavía hay una alternativa muy
importante que es usar la jurisdicción
nacional usar el concepto de
jurisdicción universal el día de que los
crímenes de guerra las atrocidades
masivas pueden juzgarse de cualquier
forma viable
después de que en febrero de 2021 ella
dal kareiva otro miembro del servicio de
inteligencia sirio fuera condenado a
cuatro años y medio de prisión por ser
cómplice de la tortura de civiles el
derras lan es el segundo veredicto de
culpabilidad y una esperanza para las
víctimas y familiares de decenas de
miles de sirios que han muerto de hambre
o han sido torturados en los centros de
detención durante el conflicto civil y
que data de 2011